let me ask you something um what's the
best thing in your life family no it's
not what if you're being honest it's the
ten seconds between start and finish
when you're not thinking about anything
no family no obligations just to you
being free
I gotta tell you this whole saving the
world Robin Hood nonsense you've been
doing recently not you bu you are
why live only a quarter-mile at a time
when you can live your whole life that
way Solana you guys have taken it
personal you were only supposed to
create a diversion Roman that will
complete destruction what you want from
me a Roman tears man is what I do
great - Hey - what play two pounds away
[Music]
holy
you know what I like about you dumb your
genuine outlook but you're assembling
the hell of a job brother when we get
back to the base beers on me you got to
go up against the only thing they can't
handle you
did you ever think you'd betray your
family the way you did today Dominic
Toretto
just turned on us oh well well she's a
good dad
I don't know why he's doing this that
wasn't done
she's a very definition of high tech
terrorism and now she's working with
your guy I think I found my team this
should be interesting
[Music]
what a play like that this is impossible
which is why you gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum
we are about to go off like this it took
longer than I expected but if you're
gonna catch dawn you guys are gonna work
together surprise
just for love I've been waiting for it
we got a tank this rope I don't know the
old Dom is in there I don't give a damn
I'm taking you down so right off this
place I planted she'd met me I don't
know maybe cuz you're in an orange
Lamborghini
[Music]
reverse glass collector yeah we are
about to go old life
[Music]
see we're going to need a bigger truck
oh you're gonna turn your back on family
you
[Music]
you